Today's radio show was first recorded back in January 2002. It was still very early after September 11, and US forces at the time were fighting in Afghanistan. Today, of course, there are many more Americans fighting in the region than there were back then, and so the show about what daily life is like for some men and women in the war on terror still seems relevant.
今天的广播节目最初录制于2002年1月。当时9·11事件过去不久，美国军队正在阿富汗作战。当然，今天在该地区作战的美国人比当时多得多，所以关于反恐战争中男女官兵日常生活的那期节目，至今看来似乎依然具有现实意义。
Our enemies are in hiding. Some live in caves. Some cross borders in disguise. Some slip from one safe house to the next. Sometimes they must go hungry. They pray. Meanwhile, on the largest warship ever built, stocked with the most advanced weapons in the world and a crew of over 5,000, an American sailor was doing her job in the war against terror.
我们的敌人躲在暗处。有些人住在洞穴里。有些人乔装打扮越过国境。有些人从一个藏身处溜到另一个。他们有时必须忍饥挨饿。他们祈祷。与此同时，在一艘有史以来最大的军舰上，装备着世界上最先进的武器，载着5000多名船员，一位美国女水兵正在反恐战争中履行她的职责。
My name is Crevon Scott. I'm just filling up the vending machines.
我叫克雷冯·斯科特。我只是在负责填补自动售货机里的货品。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: Is that your full-time job?
这是你的全职工作吗？
Yes.
是的。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: It's your full-time job?
是你的全职工作？
Yeah, filling up vending machines all day for 12 hours.
是的，整天补货，每天12个小时。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: A few weeks ago, This American Life producers Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and I flew halfway around the world to spend some time on the USS John C. Stennis. The Stennis is one of two aircraft carriers that are launching jet fighters to support the ground troops in Afghanistan. Alex is the one who talked to Crevon Scott.
几周前，本期《美国生活》的制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格、温迪·多尔和我飞到了地球的另一端，在“约翰·C·斯坦尼斯”号航空母舰上待了一段时间。斯坦尼斯号是两艘支援阿富汗地面部队、执行战斗机起降任务的航母之一。亚历克斯采访了克雷冯·斯科特。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: What are the big sellers?
哪些东西卖得最好？
Right now, it's Snickers and Starburst. Snickers goes real fast.
现在是士力架和星爆软糖。士力架卖得非常快。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: What's the least favorite candy on board?
船上最不受欢迎的糖果是什么？
(SUBJECT) CREVON SCOTT: Bonkers, the fruit chews. We got boxes of those, and still have them. Sometimes if we don't have anything else, we'll just put all rows of Bonkers, and they'll still stay in here.
Bonkers水果嚼嚼糖。我们收到了很多箱那种糖，到现在还没卖完。有时候如果没别的卖了，我们就把所有货架都摆上Bonkers，结果它们还是卖不掉。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: So people hate Bonkers?
所以大家都不喜欢Bonkers？
(SUBJECT) CREVON SCOTT: Yeah.
是的。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: Nobody likes them.
没人喜欢它们。
(SUBJECT) CREVON SCOTT: We've still got them. But we've been ordering a whole lot of new stuff, so I've been trying to keep a whole variety of things in here, like Crunch 'n Munch. We just got the Crunch 'n Munch, and the Cheez-Its we normally didn't have in here.
它们还在那儿。但我们一直在订购很多新货，所以我尽量让品种多样化，比如Crunch 'n Munch爆米花。我们刚进了Crunch 'n Munch，还有以前没卖过的奶酪味Cheez-Its饼干。
Cheez-Its?
Cheez-Its饼干？
(SUBJECT) CREVON SCOTT: Yeah, the Cheeze-Its. The different kind of Cheez-Its.
对，就是Cheeze-Its。各种不同的Cheez-Its。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Our enemies, needless to say, are not supplied with Crunch 'n Munch. Yes, we're at war, and yes, that means thousands of Americans are in Kandahar and Kabul and other very dangerous places, doing very dangerous things. But for every person on the front lines, there are dozens backing them up with equipment, logistical support, and Cheez-Its. This aircraft carrier has only 50 or 60 pilots on board who actually drop bombs, who actually take part in combat. Everyone else is here, over 5,000 people, to get them in the air.
不用说，我们的敌军可没有Crunch 'n Munch供应。是的，我们正处于战争状态，这意味着数以千计的美国人在坎大哈、喀布尔和其他非常危险的地方，做着非常危险的事情。但对于前线的每一个人，背后都有几十个人通过装备、后勤支援和Cheez-Its饼干来支持他们。这艘航母上只有50或60名飞行员真正执行投弹任务，参与作战。船上剩下的5000多人都在这里，就是为了让他们能飞上天。
Back home, over the last few months, we've heard about the pilots. We've heard about the people doing more heroic work. But everybody else on this ship is also at war, is also far from home, is also sacrificing something to be here, and we wanted to hear their stories too. It's one thing to turn your life upside down to go shoot bullets at bad guys. It's another to give up everything to go fill candy machines 12 hours a day.
在国内，过去几个月里，我们听到了关于飞行员的事迹。我们听到了关于那些从事更英勇工作的人的故事。但船上的其他人也在战争中，也远离家乡，也为了在这里而做出牺牲，我们也想听听他们的故事。改变生活去向坏人开枪是一回事，放弃一切每天花12小时填补糖果机则是另一回事。
In the months since the USS Stennis embarked for the Arabian Sea, Crevon has only gone outside twice. If you picture for a moment what an aircraft carrier looks like, the deck of the ship, that big, flat deck, is where jets take off and land, so you can't just walk around up there. She sees daylight maybe once a day. She's 20 years old. It's her first time away from home.
自斯坦尼斯号启程前往阿拉伯海以来的几个月里，克雷冯只去过外面两次。如果你想象一下航空母舰的样子，船的甲板，那块巨大的平坦甲板，是喷气式飞机起降的地方，所以你不能随便在上面走动。她可能每天只能见到一次日光。她今年20岁。这是她第一次离家。
(SUBJECT) CREVON SCOTT: You know, the hardest part is just missing home, the home thing. If I can get over that, then I'll be all right. When I first got here, I was really bad. I cried every day, and stuff like that. My parents are really helpful. They email me every day and stuff.
你知道，最难受的就是想家，关于家的一切。如果我能克服这一点，我就没事了。我刚到这儿的时候，状态非常糟糕。我每天都在哭之类的。我的父母非常支持我。他们每天给我发邮件之类的。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Today on our program, everyday life aboard a ship at war, what it's really like. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Alex and Wendy and I went to the Stennis together, and throughout this hour you'll hear from all three of us.
今天在我们的节目中，将带您了解战舰上的日常生活，看看那是什么样的。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是伊拉·格拉斯。亚历克斯、温迪和我一起去了斯坦尼斯号，在这一个小时里，您将听到我们三人的讲述。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: We got to the Stennis about six weeks after the ship arrived in the North Arabian Sea.
我们在斯坦尼斯号抵达北阿拉伯海大约六周后登上了该舰。
The other aircraft carrier on duty there, the Theodore Roosevelt, sends planes during the day, and the Stennis sends them at night. This means that reveille is called over the ship's PA system to wake everybody up for work at 7:00 PM. We expected a bugle, or at least a recording of a bugle, but it turns out to be sort of no frills.
另一艘在那里值勤的航空母舰“西奥多·罗斯福”号在白天派出飞机，而斯坦尼斯号则在夜间派出飞机。这意味着船上的广播系统会在下午7点播放起床号，叫醒大家开始工作。我们本以为会有小号声，或者至少是小号的录音，但结果却非常朴实无华。
(SUBJECT) PA SYSTEM: Reveille, reveille, all hands heave out.
起床了，起床了，全体人员起床。
From the time we get up, we're led everywhere by a group of public affairs officers, who are, contrary to what you think they might be-- well, contrary to what we suspected they'd be anyway-- good-humored and quite helpful. Our first day they lead us down a long passageway. Every 15 feet or so there's a junction, and other hallways go off to the left or right, and ladders go up and down. It's like walking through a big Habitrail.
从我们起床的那一刻起，我们就一直由一组公共事务官带领，与你们想象中可能的样子相反——好吧，至少与我们猜测的相反——他们其实幽默风趣且非常乐于助人。第一天，他们带着我们穿过一条长长的过道。每隔15英尺左右就有一个岔路口，其他走廊通向左边或右边，还有楼梯上下。这就像走在一个巨大的宠物仓鼠迷宫里。
(SUBJECT) OFFICER 1: Make a left there.
在那儿向左转。
(SUBJECT) OFFICER 2: Keep going.
继续走。
Remember, the boat is huge. It's four and 1/2 acres. But most of the life of the ship takes place here, in the eight stories of rooms and passageways below the flight deck. There are no windows on these decks, and the boat is so big that in good weather, it doesn't really even sway. And so most of the time, the sensation is less being at sea than being underground in some sort of huge subterranean warren.
记住，这艘船非常巨大。有4.5英亩那么大。但船上的大部分生活都发生在这里，也就是飞行甲板下方八层楼高的房间和过道里。这些甲板上没有窗户，船体大到在天气好的时候，甚至感觉不到摇晃。所以大部分时间，与其说是在海上，不如说更像是被困在某种巨大的地下洞穴里。
(SUBJECT) OFFICER 2: Can I cut through?
我能穿过去吗？
You're constantly squeezing by people coming from the other direction.
你得不断地侧身挤过从对面走来的人。
(SUBJECT) OFFICER 2: Hey you.
嘿，你。
(SUBJECT) SAILOR 1: Are you still awake?
你还没睡吗？
(SUBJECT) OFFICER 2: I'm still awake.
我还没睡。
After five minutes of winding our way through these narrow corridors, we come to a big, rounded steel door. It's maybe five feet tall, airtight. It's got a big lever in the middle. Someone turns it, and we climb through into one of the largest rooms we've ever seen.
在这些狭窄的走廊里绕了五分钟后，我们来到了一扇圆形的巨大钢门前。它大约五英尺高，气密性很好。中间有一个大杠杆。有人转动它，我们爬进去，进入了我们见过最大的房间之一。
This is the hangar deck. It's two football fields long, three stories tall. Entering it is like walking through a closet door and finding yourself at the pitcher's mound in the Astrodome. We walk past parked fighter planes and hundreds of people, all scurrying around, pushing hand trucks, talking into walkie-talkies. And then we arrive at the hangar bay door, which is basically a three-story hole in the side of the ship.
这就是机库甲板。它有两个足球场长，三层楼高。走进这里就像穿过壁橱门，突然发现自己站在了棒球场投手丘上。我们走过停放的战斗机和成百上千人，他们都在匆忙走动，推着手推车，对着对讲机说话。然后我们到达了机库舱门，这基本上是船侧面一个三层楼高的洞。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: It's nighttime. Peering out, we can make out the shadowy outline and red running lights of another huge boat traveling at the same speed we are, maybe 100 yards away. A half dozen steel cables stretch between the two ships. Helicopters dip and swerve back and forth. And then, out of the darkness, two pallets with hundreds of pounds of food come swinging in on a cable.
现在是夜晚。向外看去，我们可以隐约看到另一艘巨轮的阴影轮廓和红色的航行灯，它正以和我们同样的速度航行，距离大约100码。两艘船之间拉着六根钢缆。直升机在两船之间摇曳穿梭。接着，从黑暗中，两块载着几百磅食物的托盘顺着缆绳滑了过来。
We just took on two pallets.
我们刚刚接收了两个托盘。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Lieutenant Commander Mark [? Semmler ?] explains that they're bringing on enough food for 5,000 people for 30 days, plus machine parts, bundles of food. People pass boxes of fresh pears and strawberries and avocados fired brigade-style. The entire operation takes over 250 people. I know everyone knows they're at war. In most jobs it doesn't feel like a war.
马克·塞姆勒中校解释说，他们正在补给足以供应5000人食用30天的食物，还有机械零件和成捆的补给。人们像传递消防水桶一样传递着新鲜的梨、草莓和牛油果。整个行动需要250多人参与。我知道每个人都知道他们在打仗。但在大多数岗位上，并不觉得这是战争。
Not at all. We do our job.
一点也不。我们只是在做我们的工作。
I know everything that's going on, but I'm still like, OK, we're living on the boat for six months.
我知道发生了什么，但我还是觉得，好吧，我们要在这条船上住六个月。
I feel like I'm doing my job the same way, and this is pretty much normal. It's not like being on the front lines with an M16 in my hand.
我觉得我做这份工作也是一样，这很正常。这不像手里拿着M16步枪在前线战斗。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Do you wish you had a job which put you more in the front lines?
你希望拥有一份能让你置身前线的工作吗？
No, man, no. Not with my wife and stuff. No, I'm very happy with what I am.
不，伙计，不。我有妻子还有别的事情。不，我对现在的状态非常满意。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Do you feel in danger here?
你觉得在这里有危险吗？
No. I mean, the most those guys got is rifles and missiles. They couldn't fire this far out into the ocean.
没有。我是说，那些家伙最多也就是些步枪和导弹。他们不可能把火炮打到这么远的海面上。
No, actually I feel like this is one of the most secure places you can be. We've got 70-plus aircraft looking for the enemy. When I'm not on a ship, I feel like it could happen anywhere. Any time you drive over a bridge, or go to a public place, it could happen. And I definitely feel safer out here.
不，实际上我觉得这里可能是最安全的地方之一了。我们有70多架飞机在搜寻敌人。当我不在船上时，我觉得危险可能随时随地发生。无论何时你开车经过一座桥，或者去公共场所，危险都可能发生。我绝对觉得在这里更安全。
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: The average age on board the ship is 21 years old, and when you ask people how they ended up here, the most common answer is, I don't know. They just shrug, and say they were failing out of school, or they wanted to see the world, or they wanted money for college. Almost all the enlistment stories can be summarized as either, I joined the Navy to straighten out my life, or, I joined the Navy because I wanted something more.
船上的平均年龄是21岁，当你问人们是怎么到这里来的时候，最常见的回答是“我不知道”。他们只是耸耸肩，说他们学习不好，或者想看看世界，或者想挣大学学费。几乎所有的应征故事都可以总结为：“我为了理清生活而加入海军”，或者“我加入海军是因为我想要更多的人生体验”。
(SUBJECT) JESSICA PHILLIPS: I'm Jessica Phillips. I got here six days ago. I'm going through training right now. So everything's still a blur. I don't even know what day it is. Wednesday? Thursday?
我叫杰西卡·菲利普斯。我六天前到这儿的。我正在接受训练。所以一切都还是很模糊。我都不知道今天是什么日子。周三？周四？
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: When I asked Jessica Phillips my question about how she ended up on this ship, she looked up at me and said, do you really want to hear this story? It all began, she said, two and half years ago, working at the mall in a Barnes & Noble, and living in the same small town where she'd grown up in Ocala, Florida.
当我问杰西卡·菲利普斯关于她怎么来到这艘船的问题时，她抬头看着我问：“你真的想听这个故事吗？”她说，这一切始于两年半前，当时她在奥卡拉一家商场的巴诺书店工作，生活在她长大的小镇里。
(SUBJECT) JESSICA PHILLIPS: Before I'd never even pay attention to military people. It was so what, you're in the Navy. You're a drunken sailor or marine. People call you bullet sponge. Why would you do that? I didn't understand why people-- personally for me, I never thought I'd be in the military. It was a split-second decision.
在那之前，我从来没关注过军人。我觉得，那又怎样，你在海军。你是酒鬼水兵或者是海军陆战队员。人们叫你“挡子弹的”。你为什么要做那个？我不明白为什么人们……就我个人而言，我从来没想过我会参军。那是一个瞬间的决定。
The place where I live is considered the black hole. Nobody gets out of there. Most people live and die there, and that's just the way it goes. You grow up with the same people. Everything stays the same. I couldn't take it anymore. So I told my-- I had two girl roommates at the time. And I looked at them. I said, you can have all my stuff. I packed up a suitcase, and I was like, I'm leaving, and I left that night. And I left them money for that month's rent and everything. Look, you need to find a new roommate. I get in my car, which was an '89 Mustang, and just putter away.
我住的地方被认为是“黑洞”。没人能从那儿逃出来。大多数人在那里生老病死，事情就是这样。你和同样的人一起长大。一切都一成不变。我受不了了。所以我告诉我的……当时我有两个女孩室友。我看着她们说，我的东西你们都可以拿走。我收拾了一个手提箱，心想，我要离开，那天晚上我就走了。我给她们留下了那个月的房租钱和所有东西。听着，你们得找个新室友。我钻进我的那辆89年的野马车，就这么慢吞吞地开走了。
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: Jessica had no idea where she was headed. There were vague thoughts of finding someplace cool and applying to college. She made her way up the coast to Raleigh, North Carolina. Jessica ended up stopping in Raleigh, moving in with friends. But without a job, she had to find other ways to make ends meet.
杰西卡不知道自己要去哪儿。她只是隐约想着找个酷一点的地方申请大学。她沿着海岸一路开到了北卡罗来纳州的罗利。杰西卡最终停在了罗利，和朋友住在一起。但没有工作，她不得不找其他方法维持生计。
(SUBJECT) JESSICA PHILLIPS: I used to go gas station to gas station, and ask people for money pretty much. I would be like listen, I'm on a road trip. Most people hand me money, $5 or something. But you can only do that for so long.
我以前经常去加油站找人要钱。我会说，听着，我在公路旅行。大多数人会给我点钱，五美元之类的。但这种事只能做一阵子。
So I was just sitting there, and I was trying to figure out what I did this for, first of all. I gave up all my stuff. I'm almost broke. I was just like, I need to figure out what I need to do. I need to do something with myself.
所以我只是坐在那儿，试图弄清楚我做这些是为了什么，首先，我放弃了所有的财产。我快破产了。我就想，我得弄清楚我该做什么。我得为自己做点什么。
We were having a party, and everybody was partying, and I'm sitting outside. And some guy comes up to talk to me, and he said something about what are you doing tomorrow? And I said, I'm going to go home and join the Navy. And he was like, what? He was just like, what are you talking about? I was like, I think I'm going to pack up, and go home and join the Navy. I was like, this is what I need to do.
我们当时在开派对，每个人都在狂欢，我坐在外面。有个家伙走过来和我搭话，他随口问明天打算做什么？我说，我要回家去加入海军。他愣住了，问：什么？他就是问，你在说什么？我说，我想我得收拾好东西，回家加入海军。我就觉得，这就是我需要做的。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: Why did the Navy pop into your head? Why Navy?
为什么海军这个念头会蹦进你的脑海？为什么是海军？
(SUBJECT) JESSICA PHILLIPS: I have no idea. I think my manager at Barnes & Noble was in the Navy for two years. She was a yeoman, but that was like 20 years ago. And that kind of like came back to me. And I think-- this sounds so cheesy though, but it was like a Navy commercial came on in between television or something. It's the one where they say that the sea is our classroom. They use the intro to some hard core rock song. I think it's a Limp Bizkit song. Maybe not. Maybe it's a Godsmack.
我不知道。我想可能是因为我在巴诺书店的经理曾当过两年海军。她是文书，但那是20年前的事了。这念头就回到了我脑海里。我想……这听起来很俗气，但在电视节目间隙播放的一个海军广告。就是那个说“大海是我们的课堂”的广告。他们用了某种硬摇滚歌曲做开场。我想是林普巴兹提特的一首歌。也许不是。也许是Godsmack的。
I don't know, but there's the carrier, and it's racing across, and they've got the jets flying over, and they got the people all smiling in their nice uniforms, and sitting in class doing their schoolwork, and the people who are sitting in front of the radar and looking at the picture. And then they're like, most people go to school, but this is our classroom. And then it says gonavy.com. So then I was like, hey, maybe I will.
我不确定，但画面里有航母，它在海上飞驰，有喷气式飞机飞过，人们穿着漂亮的制服微笑着，坐在教室里做作业，还有人坐在雷达前看着屏幕。然后他们说，大多数人去学校，但这是我们的课堂。最后屏幕上显示gonavy.com。于是我就想，嘿，也许我也会去。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: From the time you told that guy at the party you were going to join the Navy to the time you were in the Navy, how many days passed?
从你告诉派对上那个家伙你要参军到你真的参军，中间过了多少天？
(SUBJECT) JESSICA PHILLIPS: Six. Five. That was a Friday, and that Wednesday I was in boot camp.
六天。五天。那是周五，到了周三我就在参加新兵训练了。
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: When I got back, I actually got a copy of the commercial from the Navy. The entire thing takes 15 seconds, and Jessica's memory of it is pretty much perfect.
我回来后，真的弄到了那个海军广告的副本。整个广告只有15秒，杰西卡的记忆力相当精准。
Why should you consider getting an education in the Navy? This is one of your classrooms. Navy, accelerate your life.
为什么你要考虑在海军接受教育？这就是你的课堂之一。海军，加速你的人生。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: And how is it for you? Once you were in boot camp, did you have second thoughts?
那对你来说感觉如何？一旦进入新兵训练营，你有过后悔吗？
(SUBJECT) JESSICA PHILLIPS: Did I ever have second thoughts. When you first get on the bus, it's a whole nice trip. Everybody's polite to you, everything else. Then you get on the bus, and you're sitting there. Some guy gets on the bus, and tells you you're not home anymore and starts yelling. It's the basic boot camp thing. I'm not your mama or your papa. Stop talking. I don't want to hear it. So I was just like, OK, they're just trying to scare me. Whatever. I'm sitting there laughing. I'm like, God, this is such a movie. I was like, how stereotypical is this?
我有没有后悔过。当你第一次上车时，一切都很顺利。每个人对你都很有礼貌，其他一切也挺好。然后你上了车，坐在那儿。有个家伙上了车，告诉你这里不是你的家了，然后就开始大吼大叫。那是典型的新兵训练流程。我不关心你是谁的爹妈。别说话。我不想听。所以我当时想，好吧，他们只是在试着吓唬我。随便吧。我坐在那儿笑。我说，天哪，这简直就是电影。我心想，这还能再刻板一点吗？
So they bus us to the Navy boot camp in Great Lakes. And we get off the bus, and it's the middle of the night. It's cold, and they're yelling at you to stand against the wall, and why can't you stand still, and everything else. And when I call your name, yell out your social. And they yell out my name, and I'm standing there yelling my social security number. They're telling me I'm not doing it loud enough. And I'm thinking, what did I do? What am I doing here?
他们把我们送到了五大湖的海军新兵训练营。我们下车的时候，是大半夜。天气很冷，他们对着你大喊让你靠墙站，问你为什么不能站好，诸如此类。当我叫到你的名字时，大声报出你的社保号。他们叫到我的名字，我站在那儿大声报出我的社保号。他们告诉我说我声音不够大。我在想，我做了什么？我在这儿干什么？
It's 5:00. Gosh, this day is so clear. It's 5:00 in the morning. And you're looking at a stranger, and you understand everything they're feeling. That was one of the few moments where you look at somebody, and you're  like, I know exactly what you're thinking. And I know what you're feeling, because I do too.
现在是5点。天哪，今天真是太清醒了。凌晨5点。你看着一个陌生人，你理解他们感受的一切。那是少数几个瞬间之一，你看着某个人，觉得，我完全明白你在想什么。我也知道你在感受什么，因为我也一样。
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: It got better, of course, and Jessica was satisfied with the Navy. At 22, she says, she's been to countries and seen things she never would have otherwise. But her feelings about the Navy became even stronger after September 11.
情况当然有所好转，杰西卡对海军感到满意。她说，22岁时她去过一些国家，看到了她原本永远不可能看到的东西。但在9·11事件之后，她对海军的感情变得更加强烈了。
(SUBJECT) JESSICA PHILLIPS: As far as September 11, a personal reflection of what it does: you become a little bit more patriotic. Before it was kind of like, maybe, ah, I'm in it. It's a job. I do my eight hours a day, and then I'm done. I'll be able to get my college money. If you had asked me before as a civilian, I'd have been like, oh, war. Make love, not war. Let's go for the hippie side of it.
关于9·11事件，个人的反思是：你变得稍微爱国了一点。之前感觉就像，也许吧，啊，我只是身在其中。这只是一份工作。我每天工作八小时，然后就结束了。我可以拿到我的大学学费。如果你在以前作为平民问我，我会说，哦，战争。要爱，不要战争。让我们走嬉皮士那一套吧。
But now it's just kind of like, I want to cry. I'm tired, so I'm going to start crying. But I look at my family, and it's just like, I'm willing to die for these people on the street, the people you're walking by. I'm willing to give, sacrifice myself for what has happened. I don't even know how to correctly say it, but when you realize that you're really fighting for something and for somebody, it kind of gets more personal.
但现在就像是，我想哭。我累了，所以我开始想哭。但我看着我的家人，就像是，我愿意为这些街上的人，那些你擦肩而过的人而死。我愿意为已经发生的事情牺牲自己。我甚至不知道该怎么准确地说出来，但当你意识到你确实在为什么人和什么事业而战时，它就会变得更加私人化。
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: Almost everyone we talked to said some version of this, even people who happened to be doing jobs they hated. They all felt proud to be out there defending their country. And sometimes while they would talk about it, an almost startled tone would creep into their voices, as if they were as surprised as anyone that this crappy job felt so different than all the other ones they'd ever done. They felt they were doing something that mattered.
我们采访的几乎每个人都说了类似的观点，即使是那些刚好做着自己讨厌工作的人。他们都为能够捍卫自己的国家而感到自豪。有时当他们谈论这些时，他们的语气中会带上一种近乎惊奇的情绪，仿佛他们和任何人一样感到吃惊——这份烂工作居然和他们做过的其他工作感觉如此不同。他们觉得自己在做一件很重要的事情。
To give you a sense of the variety of things going on at any given moment on board the Stennis, here's what we passed walking down just one hallway. On O3 deck was Senior Chief Barbara Mendoza, an electronics repair shop, a room in charge of anti-submarine warfare, an air traffic control center, a conference room that they actually call the war room, the office of the admiral who's in charge of this ship and the six other ships and two nuclear-powered subs which travel with it at all times, protecting it.
为了让你了解斯坦尼斯号上随时发生的各种事情，这里是我们走过一条走廊时所经过的地方。在O3甲板上有高级主管芭芭拉·门多萨、电子维修店、负责反潜战的房间、空中交通管制中心、一个他们实际称为“作战室”的会议室，还有负责这艘船以及随时保护它的另外六艘船和两艘核动力潜艇的将军办公室。
(SUBJECT) BARBARA MENDOZA: This is CVIC.
这是CVIC。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: CVIC means?
CVIC是什么意思？
(SUBJECT) BARBARA MENDOZA: Intelligence. They're not really that intelligent. No, they are. And this is the air wing commander's office.
情报中心。他们其实没那么聪明。不，他们很聪明。这是航空联队指挥官的办公室。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: Toward the back of the boat, some corridors have red lights on instead of white, indicating people are asleep. We pass a guy playing Nintendo. Video games of all sorts are huge on the Stennis in off-hours. A guy runs past us with a bloody nose. We never find out the story behind that. There's a workout room, and next to it a locked door that music's blaring out of. Barbara raps on the door.
在船尾方向，一些走廊亮着红灯而不是白灯，表示有人在睡觉。我们经过一个正在玩任天堂的家伙。在休息时间，各种视频游戏在斯坦尼斯号上非常流行。一个流鼻血的家伙从我们身边跑过。我们从来没弄清楚这背后的故事。那里有一个健身房，旁边是一个锁着的房间，里面震耳欲聋地播放着音乐。芭芭拉敲了敲门。
(SUBJECT) BARBARA MENDOZA: [KNOCKING] They're not going to be able to hear me.
（敲门声）他们听不到我的声音。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: On the door is a sign-up sheet for bands who can use the room as a rehearsal space. There are lots of bands on board. This one's called Recoil.
门上有一个乐队报名表，可以使用这个房间作为排练空间。船上有很多乐队。这一支叫“反冲”。
(SUBJECT) BARBARA MENDOZA: You feel the door is just echoing. It's just vibrating. [KNOCKING]
你感觉门在回响。它只是在震动。（敲门声）
(HOST) WENDY DORR: The guys in Recoil work on planes or on the flight deck. It can be hard to work out their schedule so they're all free to rehearse at the same time.
“反冲”乐队的成员在飞机上或飞行甲板上工作。要协调他们的日程安排，让他们都能在同一时间排练，可能会很难。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: So where do you draw your inspiration from?
那么你们的灵感来自哪里？
A lot of stuff. That song comes from my ex-wife. I recently got divorced, and it came out of nowhere. I got blindsided. So I draw on my personal experiences.
很多东西。那首歌来自我的前妻。我最近离婚了，它出乎意料地发生了。我被打了个措手不及。所以我从我的个人经历中汲取灵感。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: And then where do you perform?
那么你们在哪里表演？
We've performed at the Steel Beach Picnic a couple days ago.
我们几天前在“钢铁海滩野餐会”上表演过。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Where's that?
那是哪儿？
Up on the flight deck. Every holiday, like Christmas, they have bands performing in the mess decks, or in the hangar bay. They're going to have a Super Bowl halftime show. We're going to play in the hangar bay.
在飞行甲板上。每个节日，比如圣诞节，他们都会在餐厅甲板或机库里安排乐队演出。他们还要举办一场超级碗中场秀。我们将在机库里演奏。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: The Super Bowl is sort of tricky for an aircraft carrier. They scheduled a day off from flying, but the quality of the ship's satellite TV reception depends on which direction they're heading, so the plan was this: at the start of the game they would set course in the most TV-friendly direction at the slowest possible speed. When they got to halftime, they would turn a 97,000-ton ship around, and then chug back as fast as possible to where they began, while Recoil and other bands played. And then, when the game started again, they would set out again in that first TV-friendly heading at the slowest possible speed.
超级碗对于航空母舰来说有点棘手。他们安排了一天不飞行，但船的卫星电视接收质量取决于他们航行的方向，所以计划是这样的：比赛开始时，他们会以最适合电视信号的方向，以尽可能慢的速度航行。当比赛进行到中场休息时，他们会掉转这艘9.7万吨的船，然后尽可能快地赶回出发地，同时由“反冲”和其他乐队进行演奏。然后，当比赛再次开始时，他们会再次设定那个电视信号最好的方向，以最慢的速度航行。
It's now just a few hours since we saw the resupply operation. We're in the ship's library. It's 11:30 at night. Summer Anderson is on a schedule where her work shift just ended. But before she goes to sleep, she comes here and waits in line for a half hour to go into one of the computers, where she can do email. While she waits, I ask her about her job, which involves moving airplanes around from one spot to another, but she cuts us off.
距离我们看到补给行动已经过了几个小时了。我们在船上的图书馆。现在是晚上11点半。萨默·安德森的工作轮班刚好结束。但在她睡觉之前，她来到这里，排了半小时队，去使用一台电脑收发邮件。在排队时，我问她关于她的工作，那涉及把飞机从一个位置移动到另一个位置，但她打断了我们。
(SUBJECT) SUMMER ANDERSON: You want to talk about something interesting?
你想聊点有趣的事情吗？
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Sure, let's talk about something interesting.
当然，我们聊点有趣的。
(SUBJECT) SUMMER ANDERSON: My job's not interesting. No, it's tedious.
我的工作没意思。不，很枯燥。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: What are you liking about being on board?
你喜欢在船上的哪些方面？
(SUBJECT) SUMMER ANDERSON: I actually love the Navy. I don't like my job per se, but I love the whole military. I like the lifestyle.
我其实爱死海军了。我就那样吧，我不喜欢我的工作本身，但我爱整个军队。我喜欢这种生活方式。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Which part of the lifestyle?
生活方式的哪一部分？
(SUBJECT) SUMMER ANDERSON: It becomes kind of like a big family. You all live together. You all dress, and talk, and eat the same exact things. We shower in the same exact showers. It becomes like a culture.
它变得有点像一个大家庭。你们住在一起。你们穿着同样的衣服，说着同样的话，吃着完全一样的东西。我们在完全一样的淋浴间洗澡。它变成了一种文化。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Summer's friend Melissa walks into the library. She's older than Summer, 25-- Summer's just 19-- and is here to write email back home.
萨默的朋友梅丽莎走进了图书馆。她比萨默大，25岁——萨默才19岁——她是来写邮件回家的。
Well, I'm a single mom. For my son's kindergarten class he has to email me, so that's why I stay up for that extra hour after work to read them.
嗯，我是个单身母亲。为了我儿子的幼儿园班级，他必须给我发邮件，所以我才会工作后多熬一个小时来读这些邮件。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: I'd assumed that Summer would also be writing to people back home. She tells me no. She's writing to friends on the ship. It's the only way to keep up with people, she says. Everybody works different hours, and there's a lot to keep up with.
我本以为萨默也会给家里写信。她告诉我没有。她是在给船上的朋友写信。她说，这是跟上大家动态的唯一途径。每个人工作时间不同，而且有很多事情需要关注。
(SUBJECT) SUMMER ANDERSON: That's the other thing about the ship. Rumors just fly. It's amazing. I found out the other day that I liked somebody I never even met. Rumors are amazing on a ship, because people get bored. I don't gossip. And it just goes way out of proportion. It's really actually kind of funny.
这就是关于这艘船的另一件事。谣言飞满天。太不可思议了。我前几天发现我喜欢上了一个我见都没见过的人。在船上谣言很厉害，因为人们太无聊了。我不爱八卦。但事情总是被夸大。其实还挺好笑的。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Most of the rumors on board have to do when they're going to get to go to shore. These circulate constantly. The second biggest subject?
船上大多数谣言都与他们什么时候可以上岸有关。这些谣言不断传播。第二大主题呢？
(SUBJECT) SUMMER ANDERSON: You know, other people. It's kind of like high school sometimes.
你知道，其他人。有时就像高中一样。
Yeah, it's like a small town in the outskirts of nowhere. You know, how everybody knows everything about everybody. You can walk up to someone, look at their name tag, and be like, oh, that's who they were talking about. OK.
是的，就像一个位于偏远地带的小镇。你知道的，每个人都知道关于每个人的所有事。你可以走到某人面前，看他们的名牌，心想，哦，这就是他们在谈论的人。好的。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: This conversation about rumors ends up getting Alex and Wendy and I in a little bit of trouble, mostly because of me. I find the entire subject so interesting that I bring it up the next place we visit, the ship's laundry. I'm having what I think is a perfectly innocent conversation with an airman named Jason [? Bess. ?] His regular job is to work on high-tech aviation electronics, but the way the Navy works is that when you first report to a ship, you do 90 days at one of the jobs that nobody signs up for when they join the Navy, that the Navy has to have someone do, or you can't actually run a navy-- cleaning, serving food, and doing laundry, thousands of pounds a day of laundry, stacked in bags to the ceiling.
这段关于谣言的谈话最终让亚历克斯、温迪和我惹上了一点麻烦，主要是因为我。我发现这个话题非常有趣，以至于在我们参观的下一个地方——船上的洗衣房时，我提了出来。我正在和一个叫杰森的航空兵进行我认为完全无辜的谈话。他的正式工作是维护高科技航空电子设备，但海军的规矩是，当你第一次上舰时，你需要做90天的苦力——没人报名加入海军是为了做这个，但海军必须有人做，否则无法维持运作——清洁、端菜、洗衣服，每天成千上万磅的衣服，袋子堆到天花板。
Right now I'm opening the dryer. This dryer holds about 100 pounds of laundry.
现在我正在开烘干机。这个烘干机大约能装100磅的衣服。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Jason, it turns out, actually doesn't mind his 90 days doing wash.
杰森，事实证明，并不介意他那90天的洗涤任务。
I don't know. I really like laundry, actually.
我不知道。其实我真的很喜欢洗衣服。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Oh yeah?
噢，是吗？
Yeah. I feel good. It's just washing laundry. My regular job is really complicated, and sometimes I have a hard time comprehending all the electronical systems, and memorizing all the different systems, and the start-ups and all that. And laundry was a good break, because it's really simple. Here all you do is you just throw it in the washer, take it out of the wash, put it in the dryer. And there's not too much complication.
是的。我觉得挺好。就是洗衣服而已。我的日常工作很复杂，有时我很难理解所有的电子系统，还要记住各种不同的系统、启动程序等等。洗衣服是个很好的休息，因为它很简单。在这里你要做的就是把它扔进洗衣机，拿出来，放进烘干机。没有太多复杂的麻烦。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: And then, at the end of this perfectly nice conversation, I bring up the new thing that I'd learned just minutes before in the library.
然后，在这次非常愉快的谈话结束时，我提起了我几分钟前在图书馆学到的新东西。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: I've heard there's a lot of rumors on board a ship, like there's always rumors. What are some of the rumors that you've heard?
我听说船上有很多谣言，就像总是有谣言一样。你听到过什么谣言吗？
Oh, you always hear rumors about when we're going to pull in, when we're not going to pull in, when we're going to see a port. And a lot of rumors about when we're going home, because some people say we're going to stay longer. Some people say we may leave earlier. Rumors about like what ports that we're going to hit on the way back, because everybody wants to go to Australia. And of course you hear rumors about different girls and different guys sleeping together, and people getting in trouble and getting caught for that.
哦，你总会听到关于我们什么时候靠港，什么时候不靠港，什么时候去港口的谣言。还有很多关于我们什么时候回家的谣言，因为有些人说我们会待得更久。有些人说我们可能会提前离开。关于回去路上会去哪些港口的谣言，因为每个人都想去澳大利亚。当然，你还会听到关于男女私通、人们因此惹上麻烦被抓的谣言。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: What happens if they caught for that?
如果他们因此被抓会怎么样？
You get in a lot of trouble. You're not allowed to have any fraternization on the ship. That's another thing that's kind of rough. I haven't had much physical contact in a long time. Even just a hug every now and then, you're not really supposed to do that in uniform, and you're always in uniform. I miss affection a lot. I do. I grew up in a very affectionate home, and I'd like to just get a hug every now and then.
你会惹上大麻烦。船上严禁任何越轨交往。这是另一件有点糟糕的事情。我已经很久没有身体接触了。哪怕是偶尔的一个拥抱，穿着制服是不被允许的，而你总是穿着制服。我非常渴望关怀。真的。我在一个充满关怀的家庭长大，我希望能偶尔得到一个拥抱。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Jason tells me another rumor or two he's heard, we say goodbye, and Wendy and Alex and I go down to get some food. Perhaps 15 minutes later, one of the public affairs officers informs me that Jason and I had been overheard talking about rumors on the Stennis, rumors about men and women sleeping together on board, and that within minutes this had been reported up the ranks, all the way to the ship's executive officer, the person who oversees the day to day operations of the Stennis. People were upset. What sort of story were we putting together anyway?
杰森又告诉了我一两个他听到的谣言，我们道了别，温迪、亚历克斯和我去吃东西。大约15分钟后，一名公共事务官通知我，我和杰森谈论斯坦尼斯号上谣言的事被偷听到了，关于男女在船上私通的谣言，几分钟内就被汇报到了最高层，一直到船上的执行官，也就是负责斯坦尼斯号日常运营的人。人们很不高兴。我们到底在写什么样的报道？
I won't bore you with the details of several rather tense conversations. Let's just say that we had inadvertently hit a nerve. It's been just eight years since women were first deployed on to combat ships and aircraft carriers, and just 10 years since the Navy was forced to rethink how women were treated in the service in the wake of the Tailhook scandal. This is all still enormously sensitive, sensitive enough that this conversation in the laundry was enough to raise red flags up and down the chain of command.
我不会用几次相当紧张的谈话细节来烦你。只能说，我们无意中触碰到了痛点。女性被部署到作战舰艇和航空母舰上才不过八年，而由于“Tailhook”性丑闻事件，海军被迫重新思考女性在部队中受到对待的方式也不过才十年。这仍然极其敏感，敏感得足以让洗衣房里的这段谈话在指挥链上引发警报。
At some point, we're brought in without our tape recorders to meet the ship's executive officer, a friendly but tightly-wound man named Jeff Miller. And he explains that when new crew members arrive for duty on the Stennis, he personally gives the speech reiterating Navy policy on male-female relationships, a policy he sums up for them as no dating. A date, he tells them, is as simple as two people walking side by side closely, heads leaning together and talking. A date is when you sit too near each other. You should be a minimum, he tells them, of two butt-widths apart. When he spots crew members sitting closer than that, he'll ask them if it's a date, and when of course they say no, he'll tell them, well then make sure it doesn't look like a date.
在某个时刻，我们被带到没有录音设备的地方去见船上的执行官，一个友好但神经紧绷的男人，名叫杰夫·米勒。他解释说，当新的船员来到斯坦尼斯号服役时，他会亲自发表讲话，重申海军关于男女关系的政策，他向他们总结这个政策为“禁止约会”。约会，他告诉他们，简单到两个人亲密地肩并肩走，脑袋凑在一起聊天就是。当你坐得太近就是约会。他告诉他们，你们至少要保持两个臀部宽的距离。当他发现船员坐得比那更近时，他会问他们这是不是约会，当他们当然说不是时，他会告诉他们，那么确保它看起来不像约会。
Which all seems sensible enough. This is a workplace, like any other, and you can't sleep with people you work with. But consider what the Navy is up against in trying to make this policy work. 12% of the crew on the Stennis is female. The average age on board, as we said, is 21 years old. That is thousands of young people cooped up together in a close space for months at a time far from home. Trying to keep people from having sex with each other in that situation is in a sense fighting nature itself.
这看起来都很合理。这是一个工作场所，和其他地方一样，你不能和同事睡觉。但考虑到海军在试图使这项政策行之有效时所面临的困难。斯坦尼斯号上12%的船员是女性。正如我们所说，船上的平均年龄是21岁。那是成千上万的年轻人连续几个月被关在一个狭小的空间里，远离家乡。在那种情况下，试图阻止人们发生性关系，在某种意义上是在对抗人类的天性。
In any case, after that incident the public affairs officers felt that it was necessary to monitor our interviews a little more closely. Lieutenant Jeff Gorell, one of these very smart, very capable people saddled with the thankless job of escorting us around the ship, a job which the lieutenant compared to herding cats, was with me on the mess deck not long after all this came to pass. We had some time to kill, and I saw a group of talkative young sailors who looked like they might be talkative interviewees. I asked Lieutenant Gorell if it will be OK to talk with them, but worried about their big mouths, he steered me instead to a serious-looking sailor named Kevin [? Wrenn. ?] This turned out to be a mistake for poor Lieutenant Gorell.
无论如何，在那件事之后，公共事务官认为有必要更密切地监控我们的采访。负责护送我们在这艘船上走动、被中尉比作“牧猫”的那项吃力不讨好的工作中，非常有能力、非常聪明的杰夫·戈雷尔中尉，在这一切发生后不久就在餐桌旁陪着我。我们还有些时间，我看到一群健谈的年轻水兵，看起来他们可能是健谈的受访者。我问戈雷尔中尉是否可以和他们谈谈，但他担心他们嘴巴太大，转而把领向了一个看起来很严肃的水兵凯文·雷恩。对于可怜的戈雷尔中尉来说，这结果证明是个错误。
I'm just ready to go home. I don't know what it's about.
我只是准备好回家了。我不知道这是关于什么的。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: How come you chose the service?
你是怎么选择服役的？
A court order.
法院命令。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Really, court-ordered?
真的，法院命令？
Yeah, that's how they do it in Texas. Instead of you going to jail, they send you to the armed service. So that's how--
是的，德克萨斯州就是这么干的。与其让你去坐牢，他们把你送到军队。所以就是这样……
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: They gave you the choice of jail or the Navy?
他们给了你坐牢还是去海军的选择？
Yeah, or the armed service, any armed service.
是的，或者武装部队，任何武装部队。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: You don't have to tell me the answer to this, but what kind of trouble were you in?
你不必回答这个问题，但你惹了什么麻烦？
Drugs.
毒品。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Drugs?
毒品？
Yeah.
是的。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: How much jail would you have had to do?
你本来要坐多久的牢？
Seven years.
七年。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: So how do you like it?
那感觉如何？
It sucks. It's like a prison on water. That's what it is. I don't really like it.
糟透了。这就像漂在水上的监狱。就是这样。我真的不喜欢它。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: This was not, of course, what Lieutenant Gorell was hoping for from young Kevin. I asked, hoping to turn things to a more positive area, if Kevin is changing. If people grow when the courts send them out here.
这当然不是戈雷尔中尉所希望从年轻凯文那里得到的。我问凯文，希望能把话题转到一个更积极的方向，问他是否在改变。法院把他们送来这里，人们是否会成长。
No, because people get flown off the ship almost every month for doing drugs and all kinds of stuff. So no, it's whatever you got inside of you. That's what's going to change you. If you don't want to be changed, you ain't going to be changed.
不，因为几乎每个月都有人因为吸毒和各种事被从船上赶走。所以不，这取决于你内心有什么。那才会改变你。如果你不想改变，你永远不会改变。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: I could practically hear the acid eating away at Lieutenant Gorell's stomach at this answer. I wracked my brain for the most completely neutral question I can ask.
在这个回答下，我几乎能听到胃酸在腐蚀戈雷尔中尉的胃。我绞尽脑汁想出一个最中立的问题来提问。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: So what do you do on your job? Like what is there to do?
那么你在工作中做什么？有什么事可做吗？
You just walk around all day. For eight hours you walk around and check spaces.
你整天走来走去。八个小时里你走来走去检查空间。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: And what are you looking for?
你在找什么？
Just people having sex, fights, anybody drinking, doing stuff they ain't supposed to do on the boat. Hopefully we'll get to see, but I haven't seen anything yet.
只是有人做爱、打架，任何人喝酒，做他们不该在船上做的事。希望我们会看到，但我还没看到什么。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: You haven't seen anything yet?
你还没看到任何事吗？
No. I've been looking, though.
没。但我一直在找。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: I glance over and catch the expression on the lieutenant's face.
我瞥了一眼，捕捉到了中尉脸上的表情。
It's actually like people are pretty well behaved on this boat.
其实船上的人表现得相当好。
No, that's not true. That's not true. I don't know who told you that, but this boat is like a love boat right now.
不，那不是真的。那不是真的。我不知道是谁告诉你那个的，但这艘船现在就像是一艘爱情之船。
(SUBJECT) JEFF GORELL: All right, you're done. If anyone ever asks you to do an interview again, say no.
杰夫·戈雷尔：好了，采访结束了。如果还有人让你再做采访，说不。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: This is what Lieutenant Gorell has to deal with all day long in the service of his country. As for the love boat aspect of living on the Stennis, a number of men and women both pointed out, with the incredibly long work hours, who has the energy?
这就是戈雷尔中尉每天在为国效力时必须面对的事情。至于生活在斯坦尼斯号上的“爱情之船”方面，一些男女船员都指出，工作时间长得离谱，谁还有体力呢？
By this point, perhaps you've noticed that everyone you've heard so far this hour sounds very, very young. One of the most amazing things about the Navy, and the military in general, is that it takes people who are so young, and then gets them to operate something as huge and complicated as the Stennis.
到目前为止，也许你已经注意到你听到的每个人听起来都很年轻。海军，乃至军队，最神奇的一点是，它征召了如此年轻的人，然后让他们去操作像斯坦尼斯号这样庞大而复杂的东西。
When I get a chance to visit the bridge and interview the captain of the Stennis, James McDonell, he makes clear that he is intensely aware of the youth of his crew. When he walks through the decks, they tend to chat him up, but on a very narrow range of "are we there yet" questions.
当我有机会参观舰桥并采访斯坦尼斯号舰长詹姆斯·麦克唐内尔时，他明确表示他非常清楚船员的年轻。当他走过甲板时，他们倾向于和他闲聊，但只限于“我们到了没”这类非常狭窄的问题。
(SUBJECT) JAMES MCDONELL: When are we going home? When is the end of cruise? What are we going to do after we get back from cruise?
我们什么时候回家？航行什么时候结束？我们航行结束后要做什么？
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: How often are you asked this question?
你多久被问到这个问题一次？
(SUBJECT) JAMES MCDONELL: Oh, several hundred times a day. So, literally, I walk around this ship, and I see the sailors, and I have to come up with a little shtick to make sure that I portray it correctly. It's not very satisfying to just say, we don't know. Although that's the truth, we don't know.
哦，每天几百次。所以，真的，我在船上走动，看到水兵们，我必须想出一套小把戏来确保我正确地表达。只说“我们不知道”并不是很令人满意。虽然这是事实，我们确实不知道。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Another thing Captain McDonell is very aware of is the need to keep everybody in touch with how they are contributing to the overall war effort. Every single day, he gets on the ship's PA system and reviews any international news that might have consequences for the Stennis.
麦克唐内尔舰长非常清楚的另一件事是，需要让每个人都了解他们是如何为整个战争努力做出贡献的。每一天，他都会通过船上的广播系统回顾任何可能对斯坦尼斯号产生后果的国际新闻。
(SUBJECT) JAMES MCDONELL: Just to kind of keep the crew connected, I just like to make sure that they keep focused on why we're out here. It's very easy, as I'm sure you've probably seen, to start letting your mind drift about other things other than the task at hand.
只是为了让船员保持联系，我只是想确保他们专注于我们为什么在这里。正如你可能已经看到的，思维开始漂移到手头任务之外的其他事情上是非常容易的。
When I have young folks up here-- I have the sailors of the day up here every day, one from the air wing and one from the ship. The interesting thing is that I will ask them just kind of, hey, do you know who the Secretary of State is? And that's about a one in three get it right. Do you know who the Secretary of Defense is? And maybe a little higher percentage, but not much more, because they're so focused on their world that it really kind of is our job to help them break out of that a little bit, and put their very hard work in the context of the big mosaic that's going on.
当我邀请年轻人上来——我每天邀请当天的水兵上来，一个来自航空联队，一个来自船上。有趣的是，我会问他们一些问题，嘿，你知道国务卿是谁吗？大概三个人里有一个能答对。你知道国防部长是谁吗？也许比例会高一点，但高不了多少，因为他们太专注于自己的世界，所以帮助他们从中解脱出来一点，并将他们的艰苦工作放在正在进行的大局中去理解，确实是我们的工作。
(SUBJECT) PA SYSTEM: [BOSUN'S WHISTLE]
（水手长哨声）
(HOST) IRA GLASS: A few hours later, we stood in a passageway and listened to the captain's daily message.
几个小时后，我们站在过道里听了舰长的日常广播。
(SUBJECT) JAMES MCDONELL: Aboard USS John C. Stennis, good day, this is the captain. Day 35 of combat operations over Afghanistan. This is an incredibly uncertain time for all of us aboard. The war on global terrorism, tensions between India and Pakistan, separate warnings from the President of the United States to Iran and Iraq--
“约翰·C·斯坦尼斯”号上的各位，日安，我是舰长。阿富汗战斗行动第35天。这对我们船上所有人来说都是一个非常不确定的时期。全球反恐战争、印度和巴基斯坦之间的紧张局势、美国总统分别对伊朗和伊拉克的警告——
(HOST) IRA GLASS: But it's the PA announcements which give you an even deeper sense of who the crew is, and what it means to supervise a shipload of young people, announcements like this one from the ship's executive officer, Jeff Miller.
但正是这些广播让您能更深入地了解船员是什么样的人，以及监督一船年轻人意味着什么，比如像这一个来自船上执行官杰夫·米勒的广播。
(SUBJECT) JEFF MILLER: The real topic I need to talk about right now is fresh water. For some reasons we're not completely sure of, we've gotten ourselves in a little bit of a bind with the amount of fresh water we have on board. I'm going--
我目前需要谈论的真正话题是淡水。由于一些我们无法完全确定的原因，我们的淡水储量遇到了点小麻烦。我正在——
(HOST) IRA GLASS: He's upbeat. He thanks them for their hard work on the problem. He urges them on to more. The tone is like a great high school football coach.
他很乐观。他感谢他们的努力工作。他督促他们做得更多。语气就像一个伟大的高中足球教练。
(SUBJECT) JEFF MILLER: So here's what I need you to do, and I need all 5,000 of us to work on this one today. We need to make sure that we're taking short Navy showers. That's a little redundant. Every Navy shower is supposed to be short. We expect the water to run for no more than two minutes. So the trick is, turn the water on, get wet, turn the water off, soap up, turn the water on, rinse off, turn the water back off again. If you're taking a Hollywood shower right now, you're going to hurt the ship. Right now, for the next 10 to 12 hours, if we can turn this around and start to build up our water reserves, we can avoid--
所以这是我需要你们做的，我需要我们5000个人今天一起解决这个问题。我们需要确保我们洗“海军式淋浴”。这有点冗余。每次海军淋浴都应该是短时间的。我们预计水流时间不超过两分钟。诀窍是，打开水，淋湿，关掉水，涂肥皂，打开水，冲洗，然后再关掉水。如果你现在在洗“好莱坞式淋浴”，你就会害了这艘船。现在，在接下来的10到12小时里，如果我们能扭转局面并开始增加我们的淡水储备，我们可以避免——
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Coming up, what it's like to drop a bomb on Afghanistan. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，轰炸阿富汗是什么感觉。稍后，从芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. This week, with tens of thousands of Marines and sailors, infantry divisions, and fighter wings, and National Guardsmen deployed in Iraq and Afghanistan and elsewhere in the war on terror, we're re-broadcasting our program from early 2002, when This American Life producers Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, and I visited the USS John C. Stennis , an aircraft carrier that at the time was cruising somewhere in the Arabian Sea, flying bombing missions over Afghanistan, and monitoring the region for Al Qaeda nautical traffic.
这里是《美国生活》。我是伊拉·格拉斯。本周，随着数以万计的海军陆战队员和水兵、步兵师、战斗机联队和国民警卫队员被部署在伊拉克、阿富汗以及反恐战争的其他地方，我们正在重新广播我们在2002年初的节目，当时制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格、温迪·多尔和我参观了“约翰·C·斯坦尼斯”号，这是一艘当时正在阿拉伯海某处巡航、在阿富汗执行轰炸任务并监测该地区基地组织海上交通的航空母舰。
We visited the briefing room at one of the air squadrons on the Stennis, a squadron that calls itself the World Famous Screwbirds. On a desk there's a big jar of red licorice and some homemade blondies that someone's girlfriend sent everybody. On the wall, there's this underground newspaper the aviators print, which is in the style of the Onion. Stories and headlines all consist of these inside jokes like, "New Billet Added to Air Wing Watch," which, um, we don't understand at all, but everybody else seems to find hilarious.
我们参观了斯坦尼斯号上一支空中中队的简报室，该中队自称为“世界著名的螺丝鸟”。桌子上有一大罐红甘草糖和一些女朋友寄来的自制布朗尼蛋糕。墙上贴着飞行员打印的一份地下报纸，风格类似于《洋葱报》。文章和标题都包含这种内部笑话，比如“航空联队观察员增加了新岗位”，这……呃，我们完全听不懂，但其他人似乎觉得好笑极了。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: On the backs of the leather chairs the pilots sit on are their call signs, the official nicknames they use over the radio on their missions. There's Frenchie, Tank, Chewie, Fish, Rain Man, Mr. Burns, that last one for a pilot who supposedly looks like the character on the Simpsons.
在飞行员乘坐的皮椅背面是他们的呼号，即他们在执行任务时通过无线电使用的官方昵称。有“法国佬”、“坦克”、“楚伊”、“鱼”、“雨人”、“伯恩斯先生”，最后一个是因为有一个飞行员长得像《辛普森一家》里的那个角色。
(SUBJECT) PILOT 1: This is Pom-Pom.
这是“蓬蓬”。
(SUBJECT) PILOT 2: Oh yeah?
噢，是吗？
(SUBJECT) PILOT 1: Pom-Pom.
蓬蓬。
(INTERVIEWER) WENDY DORR: Interesting.
有趣。
(SUBJECT) PILOT 2: Yeah, fascinating.
是啊，太迷人了。
(SUBJECT) PILOT 1: Well yeah, there's a story behind it, though. I think I know it. Hmm, what was it? Oh, one of us sitting here, call sign Pom-Pom, was a cheerleader in college.
嗯，是的，它背后有个故事，尽管如此。我想我知道。嗯，是什么来着？哦，我们中坐在这儿的一个人，呼号“蓬蓬”，在大学里是个啦啦队长。
(SUBJECT) PILOT 2: Good friend. We're very close here.
好朋友。我们在这儿很亲密。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: One of them shows us the official drawing of the squadron mascot, and quietly points out that it's a bird whose wing has a middle feather extended like a middle finger.
他们其中一人向我们展示了中队吉祥物的官方绘画，并低声指出那是一只翅膀上中指竖起的小鸟，就像竖中指一样。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: At 4:00 AM, nine of these guys sit down in their flight suits to watch an intelligence briefing that comes in over closed circuit TV. Then a young guy named Steve [? Coppler ?] stands up in front.
凌晨4点，九个家伙穿着飞行服坐下来看通过闭路电视播放的情报简报。然后一个叫史蒂夫·科普勒的年轻人站在前面。
All right. Good morning. Briefing here for our [? XAR ?] mission. 702, 705, and we've got Gonzo in 706. I'd like you to act as a fill.
好了。早上好。这是我们任务的简报。702，705，我们有冈佐在706。我希望你担任替补。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Watching him, it occurs to me how rare it is as an adult to hear somebody speak in your own language for 10 minutes, and not understand a word he's saying.
看着他，我意识到作为成年人，听别人用你的母语讲了10分钟而一个字都听不懂，是多么罕见。
Divert field, we're working blue water ops. If we need to divert and we're feet dry, you know where we're going. And if we're feet wet, we'll go to Masirah there.
改道机场，我们正在进行蓝水作业。如果我们需要改道而且我们在陆地上方，你知道我们要去哪儿。如果我们是在水上方，我们会去那边的马西拉。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Then they suit up. It's a crazy amount of survival gear, 20 to 25 pounds worth, including  the parachute, survival knife, radios, flares, and something called a blood chit. Screwbirds' commanding officer, Ross Myers, a trim man with the call sign Monkey Butt stitched on to his Navy coveralls in neat block letters, pulls one out to show us. It's a piece of paper with an American flag and a serial number, with the same message in several languages.
然后他们换装。这是极其惊人的生存装备量，重达20到25磅，包括降落伞、救生刀、无线电、信号弹，还有一种叫“血契”的东西。螺丝鸟中队的指挥官罗斯·迈尔斯，一个精干的人，海军连体工作服上用整齐的印刷体缝着“猴子屁股”的呼号，拿出一个来向我们展示。这是一张印有美国国旗和序列号的纸，上面有几种语言的相同信息。
(SUBJECT) ROSS MYERS: Oh, Arabic, English, Dari, Pashto, Uzbek-- which would have to be for Uzbekistan-- Persian, Farsi.
哦，阿拉伯语、英语、达里语、普什图语、乌兹别克语——那必须是为乌兹别克斯坦准备的——波斯语、法尔西语。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: And then in English it gives a translation.
然后英语里有一个翻译。
(SUBJECT) ROSS MYERS: Yes.
是的。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: It says--
它说——
(SUBJECT) ROSS MYERS: I'm an American, and do not speak your language. I will not harm you. I bear no malice towards your people. My friend, please provide me food, water, shelter, and necessary medical attention. Also please provide safe passage to the nearest friendly forces of any country supporting the Americans and their allies. You will be rewarded for assisting me when you present this number to American authorities.
它说：“我是一名美国人，不会说你们的语言。我不会伤害你们。我对你们的人民没有任何恶意。我的朋友，请给我提供食物、水、住所和必要的医疗救助。也请给我提供前往支持美国及其盟国的任何国家最近友军的安全通道。当你把这个号码提交给美国当局时，你将因为协助我而获得奖励。”
(SUBJECT) PA SYSTEM: Everybody maintain their [UNINTELLIGIBLE] station. We'll be taking the next aircraft out now, 20 minutes.
请所有人坚守岗位。我们将在20分钟后进行下一架飞机的起飞。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: The Screwbirds head out to their planes. An aircraft carrier's main mission is to fly planes, but when you see what it takes to launch or land a jet on a boat, what you realize is that human beings should not be doing this at all.
螺丝鸟中队出发前往他们的飞机。航空母舰的主要任务是飞行飞机，但当你看到在船上起降喷气式飞机需要什么时，你意识到人类根本不应该做这种事。
The runway is just too short. For the planes to get enough lift under their wings, the crew actually has to drive the boat at top speed into the wind. Then the front wheel of the plane is attached to machinery under the deck, the catapult, which literally flings it off the edge of the deck like a pebble from a slingshot.
跑道太短了。为了让飞机在机翼下获得足够的升力，船员必须开动军舰以最高速度迎风航行。然后飞机的起落架被连接到甲板下的机器上，即弹射器，它字面上把飞机像弹弓里飞出的鹅卵石一样甩出了甲板边缘。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: Landing the plane on the deck is much harder than taking off, and it's very, very dangerous. The head of the Screwbirds, Ross Myers, aka Monkey Butt, says that in his 16 years of service, he's personally seen six of his friends crash into the back of the boat while trying to land. None of them survived.
降落飞机比起飞要困难得多，而且非常、非常危险。螺丝鸟中队的负责人罗斯·迈尔斯，也就是“猴子屁股”，说他在服役的16年里，亲眼见过他的六个朋友在尝试降落时撞在了船尾。他们中没有一个幸存下来。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Basically what you're trying to do is latch a hook that hangs from the back of your plane on to one of four cables that are stretched across the deck. An airman named Dave Cruz explains how it works. The pilot looks at something called the ball, which indicates if he's coming in on target, and talks to guys called LSOs-- they're fellow pilots actually, who stand right on deck.
基本上你试图做的是把挂在飞机后面的钩子钩在拉过甲板的四根电缆中的一根上。一个叫戴夫·克鲁兹的水兵解释了它是如何运作的。飞行员看着一种叫“球”的东西，它指示他是否瞄准了目标，并和被称为LSO的人交谈——他们实际上也是飞行员，就站在甲板上。
(SUBJECT) DAVE CRUZ: And it's up to the LSOs to guide him in.
由LSO引导他进来。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: They're talking to him over the radio?
他们在无线电里和他说话？
(SUBJECT) DAVE CRUZ: Right now they're talking to that next guy who are coming in, which is a Tomcat, which is 3/4 of a mile. He's calling the ball, and stating the fuel state.
现在他们在和下一个进场的家伙说话，那是一架雄猫战机，距离四分之三英里。他正在报告球和燃油状态。
115 on course, on glide path, 3/4 of a mile. Call the ball.
115在航线上，在下滑道上，四分之三英里。报告球。
(SUBJECT) PILOT 3: 115, Tomcat ball 8.0.
115，雄猫球，8.0。
Roger ball, 28 knots down the angle.
收到球，角下滑道28节。
(SUBJECT) DAVE CRUZ: Right now it's about a quarter of a mile. Right now he's just telling him you're on ball, and it should be good to go.
现在大约四分之一英里了。现在他只是在告诉他你在球上，应该没问题了。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: He's right over the edge of the deck?
他刚好在甲板边缘上方？
(SUBJECT) DAVE CRUZ: Yes. That is too short. That is too short, which is the one wire. That is too short.
是的。太短了。太短了，也就是一号线。太短了。
The one wire is the wire closest to the rear of the boat, and if you catch it, that means that you were dangerously close to going too low and slamming into the back of the carrier. Sometimes a pilot can't straighten out his approach enough, and the LSOs have to wave him off. It can get a little tense.
一号线是离船尾最近的线，如果你钩住它，意味着你危险地接近过低，并撞在了航母的尾部。有时飞行员无法足够理顺他的进场航线，LSO必须挥手示意他复飞。可能会有点紧张。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Here comes another one. Just describe how he's doing.
又来了一架。描述一下他的表现。
(SUBJECT) DAVE CRUZ: All right, he's turning. He's turning into the 3/4 mile now.
好了，他正在转弯。他现在正在转弯进四分之三英里。
Roger ball, 28 knots down the angle.
收到球，角下滑道28节。
(SUBJECT) DAVE CRUZ: And right now he's a little too low. All right, now the pilot should be telling him, kind of give it a little throttle.
现在他有点太低了。好了，现在飞行员应该在告诉他，加油门。
Don't settle. Power. Power. Wave off, wave off.
不要沉下去。动力。动力。复飞，复飞。
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: One deck below, in the Blue Diamond Squadron briefing room, I talked to a pilot named Jeremy Markin about what it's like when things don't go well during a landing.
在下一层甲板的“蓝钻”中队简报室，我采访了一位名叫杰里米·马尔金的飞行员，谈到了降落时进展不顺利是什么感觉。
(SUBJECT) JEREMY MARKIN: Who knows what happens? Maybe you lose an important instrument inside, and it's nighttime, and maybe there's weather. And so you're in the goo, we call it, inside the clouds. It's dark. So you tell yourself you've got to fly the best pass ever, and you come down, and just one thing leads to another.
谁知道会发生什么？也许你内部丢失了一个重要仪器，现在是晚上，也许天气不好。所以你在我们称之为“胶状物”的云层里。天很黑。所以你告诉自己必须飞出有史以来最好的一次进场，你下来了，一件事情导致了另一件事情。
And the next thing you know, you're looking at the back of the boat, and you're close to it, and you've got guys screaming at you. You put in the afterburners, and your hook touches down a couple feet past the back of the boat. And you go taxi into the one wire there, high speeds, and realize they caught you. Your legs are shaking. You're still on blower. Your lights are still on, and the air boss says, we got you, you can relax now. And it's kind of hard to relax right away. You kind of got to unwind for a little bit.
然后下一件事你知道的就是，你看着船尾，你离它很近，有人对着你尖叫。你打开加力燃烧室，你的钩子在离船尾几英尺处着陆。你以高速滑行到那一号线，意识到他们钩住你了。你的腿在发抖。你还在加力档上。你的灯还亮着，航空指挥官说，我们抓住你了，你现在可以放松了。而且很难马上放松。你需要一点时间来放松一下。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: You said you're hooking it to the back of the boat by a couple inches. What does that mean?
你说你离船尾只有几英寸钩住它。那是什么意思？
(SUBJECT) JEREMY MARKIN: Well, obviously the hook hit the back of the boat. That means your plane hit the back of the boat. It wouldn't be good.
很明显，钩子撞到了船尾。这意味着你的飞机撞到了船尾。那可不太好。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: The Blue Diamonds' briefing room is just like the Screwbirds' room, only a little more spartan and a little more macho, including the nicknames, which make Monkey Butt sound almost dignified by comparison.
蓝钻中队的简报室和螺丝鸟中队的房间一样，只是更简朴、更男子气概，包括昵称，这使得“猴子屁股”相比之下显得几乎庄重了。
(SUBJECT) DAVE BALSITIS: Balls, Scrote, Itchy. I got Itchy for a while because my last name is Balsitis. Looks like Balls-itis, sort of like some kind of disease.
“球”、“阴囊”、“发痒”。我有段时间叫“发痒”，因为我姓Balsitis。看起来像“Balls-itis”，有点像某种疾病。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: Both Alex and I hung out with the Blue Diamonds for about an hour. I interviewed Dave Balsitis on one side of the room, while Alex interviewed another pilot, Jeremy Markin, on the other side. And what struck us when we got home is how closely they agree on some things, and how far apart they are on others.
亚历克斯和我都在蓝钻中队待了一个小时左右。我在房间的一边采访了戴夫·巴尔西蒂斯，而亚历克斯在另一边采访了另一位飞行员杰里米·马尔金。让我们回家时震惊的是他们在某些事情上达成一致的程度，以及他们在另一些事情上的差距有多大。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: How long does it take to get to Afghanistan?
去阿富汗需要多长时间？
(SUBJECT) JEREMY MARKIN: Anywhere from an hour and a half to two hours. It depends on where you're going.
从一个半小时到两个小时不等。取决于你要去哪里。
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: And what's it like over in Afghanistan? What does it look like?
阿富汗那边是什么样的？看起来像什么？
(SUBJECT) JEREMY MARKIN: Actually it looks pretty in the mountainous areas. Snow on the mountains, looks like real nice mountain peaks.
实际上在山区看起来很漂亮。山上有雪，看起来像真正美好的山峰。
(INTERVIEWER) WENDY DORR: What does it look like when you fly over Afghanistan, and you fly over these targets?
当你飞越阿富汗，飞过这些目标时，看起来是什么样的？
(SUBJECT) DAVE BALSITIS: I can't cuss, can I?
我可以骂人吗？
(INTERVIEWER) WENDY DORR: You can, but we'll have to beep it out.
你可以，但我们得消音。
(SUBJECT) DAVE BALSITIS: OK. It's a [BLEEP] hole. It really is. There is absolutely nothing down there. I don't see anything worth fighting for down there. It's all sand, rocks. I don't know how they live down there.
好的。这是一个“（哔——）洞”。真的是。下面什么都没有。我看不到下面有任何值得战斗的东西。全是沙子、石头。我不知道他们怎么住在下面。
(SUBJECT) JEREMY MARKIN: Yeah, it's probably not much different from out near Glamis in southern California or something. There's dunes, mountains. It looks like a beautiful country.
是啊，这可能和加州南部的格拉米斯附近没什么两样。有沙丘、山脉。看起来是一个美丽的国家。
(SUBJECT) DAVE BALSITIS: There's no color. There's no irrigation, no lakes, no streams, no farms. Just brown, and some snow. So it's pretty ugly.
没有颜色。没有灌溉，没有湖泊，没有溪流，没有农场。只有棕色，还有一些雪。所以很丑。
(SUBJECT) JEREMY MARKIN: When you're actually doing what you're doing, you're kind of so busy that you don't really have a lot of time to sit back and go hey, look at the scenery. But in those moments, those positive moments you have, and you look around, the world's a beautiful place. It's kind of weird to imagine up that high and you're looking down. It looks so beautiful, and then you get snapped back in to what's going on down there, and you got to refocus.
当你真正做你做的事时，你太忙了，所以你真的没有太多时间坐下来看看风景。但在那些时刻，那些你拥有的积极时刻，你环顾四周，世界是一个美丽的地方。在那高处往下看感觉很奇怪。看起来如此美丽，然后你被拽回正在下面发生的事情中，你必须重新集中注意力。
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: This might be sort of a bonehead civilian question, but is it hard to drop a bomb?
这可能是一个愚蠢的平民问题，但投弹很难吗？
(SUBJECT) JEREMY MARKIN: Oh, you mean like in almost a moral sense?
哦，你是说在某种道德层面上？
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: Emotional or--
情感上或者——
(SUBJECT) JEREMY MARKIN: Emotional, it's a double-edged emotion. It's what you train for your whole life. The fact of you doing it, doing it correctly, and you drop your bomb on the target, it's emotional from a hey, I did my job. And just that I was trained, and I did it well. While you're up there, I don't really think about the other side of the sword. It's my job to go up there and drop bombs, and so I do it.
情感上，这是一种双重情感。这是你一生训练的目的。你做这件事的事实，正确地做这件事，你把炸弹投在目标上，这在“嘿，我完成了我的工作”层面上是情绪化的。而且只是因为我接受过训练，我做得很好。当你在那里时，我并没有真正考虑剑的另一面。我的工作就是上去投弹，所以我做了。
(SUBJECT) DAVE BALSITIS: I feel no remorse about dropping a bomb on them down below. It's not sadistic. It's just I think it's the right thing. Someone came into our house and trampled on our land, and to go on their land and absolutely pulverize them makes me feel very warm inside. I think that's great. I'm just glad I could be part of the team that's out here doing it, and dropping bombs on the bad people. I sleep at night.
我对向他们投弹没有感到任何悔恨。这不残忍。我只是觉得这是正确的做法。有人闯进了我们的家，践踏了我们的土地，去他们的土地上彻底粉碎他们让我感到非常温暖。我觉得这太棒了。我只是很高兴我能成为在这里做这件事、向坏人投弹的团队的一员。我晚上睡得着觉。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: It's 7:30 in the morning, and it's over 12 hours since reveille first called everyone to work. For most people it's the end of the work day. In the mess hall on the second deck, Cynthia and David have just finished their dinner, and they're waiting for the 8 o'clock movie, Exit Wounds, to begin.
现在是早上7点半，距离起床号叫醒大家已经超过12个小时了。对大多数人来说，这是工作日的结束。在第二甲板的餐厅里，辛西娅和大卫刚刚吃完晚饭，他们正在等8点的电影《伤痕累累》开始。
Every now and then we get to watch a chick movie.
偶尔我们能看一部“女孩电影”。
Yeah, we got to watch Stepmom the other day. Yes.
是的，我们前几天看了《继母》。是的。
(SUBJECT) CYNTHIA: Yeah, I like Stepmom, Steel Magnolias. They've been showing that one lately. They've got it on board.
是的，我喜欢《继母》、《钢木兰花》。他们最近一直在放那一部。船上有。
(SUBJECT) DAVID: Oh yeah, I haven't seen that one.
哦是吗，我还没看过那部。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: There are TVs just about everywhere people are not working on the ship, with two channels of movies and network shows 24 hours a day.
船上到处都有电视，人们工作以外的地方，全天24小时播放两套电影和电视节目。
Every Tuesday night we have a movie night where we'll pick a movie through email. We vote on what we want to see.
每个周二晚上我们都有电影之夜，我们会通过电子邮件挑选电影。我们投票决定我们想看什么。
I voted for Miss Congeniality. I'm so going to watch that tonight.
我投了《特工佳丽》。我今晚一定会看那个。
(SUBJECT) DAVID: As did I.
我也是。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: Sitting there side by side in their matching navy blue jumpsuits, they look like they're best friends, if there was such a thing for a man and a woman to be on a Navy ship. They're both reading the Left Behind series. He's on book two. She's on book four. They love playing The Game of Life on Cynthia's PlayStation, and they both enjoy a good chick movie.
他们并排坐在匹配的海军蓝连体服里，看起来他们是最好的朋友，如果男人和女人在海军军舰上能成为朋友的话。他们都在读《末日迷踪》系列。他在读第二本。她在读第四本。他们喜欢在辛西娅的PlayStation上玩《人生游戏》，他们都喜欢好电影。
David joined the Navy so he could get out of his small town in Iowa, and Cynthia joined so she could get her and her three kids off of welfare, and it worked. They're are all doing great now, she says.
大卫加入海军是为了离开他在爱荷华州的小镇，辛西娅加入是为了让她和她的三个孩子摆脱福利，结果成功了。她说，他们现在都很好。
And I've said this before. People laugh at me, but when I come out to sea, it's like a break for me, because at home I've got kids to take care of, a house to take care of. And I get out here, and all I've got to do is take care of myself, go to work, and go to sleep, kill time in between. So it's kind of a break being out here for me.
而且我之前说过。人们嘲笑我，但当我出海时，这对我来说就像是一个休息，因为在家里我有孩子要照顾，房子要照顾。我来到这里，我所要做的只是照顾好自己，工作，睡觉，在期间消磨时间。所以在这里对我来说算是一种休息。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: Even though she has 11 years of service and he has 13, both with decent rank, this is how they live. David sleeps in a room called a berthing with 196 other guys, and he's one of the oldest at 34. Each sailor gets a bunk bed with a locker underneath it, and their entire personal space is six feet long, a foot and a half tall, and about two feet wide.
尽管她有11年的服役经历，他有13年，都有不错的军衔，但他们就是这样生活的。大卫住在一个叫铺位的房间里，里面有196个其他家伙，34岁的他是最年长的人之一。每个水兵都有一个带锁柜的双层床，他们整个个人空间有6英尺长、1.5英尺高、大约2英尺宽。
And it's set up in the berthing, it's set up kind of in areas. You'll have this one little neighborhood that's listening to this music, and I'm over in the old folks place. Most of us listen to country music or something slow.
它被设置在铺位区，有点分区域。你会有一个听这种音乐的小社区，而我在老人家住的地方。我们大多数人听乡村音乐或其他缓慢的东西。
See, I live in a 26-person berthing, so it's not quite as bad as 197. A lot of us have brought stuff to make it kind of homey. Mine's Tweety Bird. I have a Tweety Bird comforter, a Tweety Bird pillows, Tweety Bird wallpaper around my rack.
你看，我住在一个26人的铺位里，所以没有197人那么糟糕。我们很多人带来了让它看起来像家一样的东西。我的那个是“翠儿鸟”。我有一个翠儿鸟被子，一个翠儿鸟枕头，我的床位周围有翠儿鸟壁纸。
You don't see that stuff down in the male berthing at all.
你在男性铺位里根本看不到那些东西。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: It's now very late, meaning 9:00 in the morning, and Senior Chief Barbara Mendoza invites us to the chief's mess, a special dining room for the ship's chiefs.
现在非常晚了，意味着早上9点，高级主管芭芭拉·门多萨邀请我们去军士长餐厅，那是为军士长准备的特殊餐厅。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: There are maybe 30 tables, with chairs stacked on top, and the floors are shiny and clean. The room is quiet, aside from the pleasant electric hum of refrigerators and drink machines, and the far-off purring of the ship's engines. In the center of the room, five middle-aged men are sitting around one of the tables. It's their nightly card game. They're playing Hearts, and they're passing around a picture of someone jumping into the ocean during a recent break, when they were allowed to swim.
大概有30张桌子，椅子堆在上面，地板闪亮整洁。房间很安静，除了冰箱和饮料机的舒适电子嗡嗡声，以及远方军舰引擎的低鸣。在房间中央，五个中年男人坐在其中一张桌子旁。这是他们每晚的牌局。他们在玩“红心大战”，并传递着一张某人在最近一次休息时跳入大海的照片，当时他们被允许游泳。
(SUBJECT) CHIEF 1: This is a perfect shot. You have Randy there jumping off the elevator, and they have a picture of a shark trying to swallow him up.
这是一个完美的镜头。你有兰迪在那儿从电梯上跳下来，他们还有一张鲨鱼试图吞掉他的照片。
Nobody can decide, though, whether he's going in or being spit back out. It's up to your interpretation.
没有人能决定他是在进去还是被吐出来。这取决于你的解读。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: The person who made this picture, this fake picture on the computer, is the person you just heard, Bobby, Bobby [? Boucher, ?] which is not his real name. Joel, which is not his real name, explains.
制作这张照片，这张电脑上的假照片的人，就是你刚才听到的那个人，鲍比，鲍比·布歇，那不是他的真名。乔尔，那不是他的真名，解释说。
Well, his real name's Mike. We call him Bobby. You want to know why?
嗯，他真名是迈克。我们叫他鲍比。你想知道为什么吗？
(INTERVIEWER) ALEX BLUMBERG: Yes.
是的。
Tell him the story of Bobby [? Boucher. ?]
告诉他鲍比·布歇的故事。
Bobby goes over here to a bar with one of our other friends, Brent. They go out, and Brent offers to buy him something. Well--
鲍比和我们其他朋友之一布伦特一起去了这儿的一家酒吧。他们出去了，布伦特提出给他买点什么。嗯——
(SUBJECT) CHIEF 1: It was a free beer.
那是免费啤酒。
(SUBJECT) MIKE: No, no, you're getting it all wrong.
不，不，你全弄错了。
OK.
好的。
We went to the--
我们去了——
(HOST) WENDY DORR: They do this over and over. Tell a tip story. Tell him about the girl in Singapore. And then they all start laughing. And then they finally tell the stories, barely getting through them because someone is always interrupting to say they're not telling the story right.
他们一遍又一遍地这样做。讲一个故事。告诉他新加坡女孩的事。然后他们都开始笑。然后他们最终讲出了故事，因为总有人打断说他们讲得不对，几乎没法讲下去。
(SUBJECT) CHIEF 2: Tell him about the tip, Bobby.
告诉他小费的事，鲍比。
No.
不。
(SUBJECT) CHIEF 3: Tell him the  tip. You've got to.
告诉他小费。你必须讲。
You got to tell him the tip, Bobby.
你得告诉他小费，鲍比。
(SUBJECT) CHIEF 3: Yeah.
是的。
(HOST) WENDY DORR: If you picture how the Navy works, there are the enlisted men, and then are the officers. The enlisted, and you've met lots of them on today's show, usually come into the Navy at 18 or 19 years old, straight out of high school. Officers come into the Navy as officers, with higher rank and privileges. The chiefs are the highest-ranking enlisted people, and anyone in the Navy will tell you they run the Navy. They're the buffer between the bosses and the people who actually do the work.
如果你想象一下海军是怎么运作的，有应征入伍的人，然后有军官。应征入伍的人，你今天在节目里见过很多，通常在18或19岁时加入海军，直接从高中出来。军官以军官身份加入海军，有更高的军衔和特权。军士长是最高军衔的应征入伍者，任何海军的人都会告诉你，他们管理着海军。他们是老板和真正做工作的人之间的缓冲。
(SUBJECT) CHIEF 4: We have to keep the high-echelon people from bothering these guys. Let them do their job, at the same time getting the job done so that these guys up here are happy.
我们必须阻止高层人员打扰这些家伙。让他们做他们的工作，同时完成工作，这样上面的这些人就很高兴。
You become like everybody's, your whole division's, father and mother all rolled into one. They need to cry on your shoulder, you let them cry on your shoulder. You need to kick them in the butt, you kick them in the butt. You listen to their problems. You talk to them. You try to help them, and that's probably what most of us spend most our time doing.
你变得就像每个人的父亲和母亲结合在一起。他们需要肩膀依靠，你就让他们依靠。你需要踢他们的屁股，你就踢他们的屁股。你听他们的问题。你和他们谈话。你试图帮助他们，这可能就是我们大多数人花费大部分时间在做的事情。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Every day, The Don says, somebody comes to him with a problem back home they need to solve, and The Don-- his real name is Brent-- helps them out. Often this means getting on the phone and contacting another chief out there somewhere. There's a whole chief-to-chief network.
每一天，“唐”说，有人来找他解决家里的问题，他需要解决，而“唐”——他的真名是布伦特——帮助他们。这通常意味着打电话联系外面某处的另一个军士长。有一个完整的军士长到军士长网络。
The chief that I need to talk to knows somebody at the command, and they can talk to that chief, who can get this whole thing going. It's a fraternity. We work together, and that's one of the biggest things about being a chief. We are one.
我需要谈话的军士长认识指挥部里的某个人，他们可以和那个军士长谈话，他可以把这一切搞定。这是一个兄弟会。我们一起工作，这是作为一名军士长最大的事情之一。我们是一体的。
The goal-- once you start out in the Navy, if you have a good chief from the beginning, your goal is to be a chief. I mean, your goal is to be that chief. And for me that was the goal.
目标——一旦你开始在海军，如果你从一开始就有个好的军士长，你的目标就是成为军士长。我的意思是，你的目标就是成为那个军士长。对我来说，这就是目标。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Who was your chief?
你的军士长是谁？
It was a guy named Chief Womack. He was my first chief in the Navy, and he was there anytime I needed anything. He was always there.
是一个叫沃马克军士长的人。他是我在海军的第一个军士长，无论我需要什么，他都在那儿。他总是在那儿。
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: Late one night, Lieutenant Gorell and a TV crew from San Diego and I are on our way back to the staterooms, when Gorell invites us into the officer's mess for a bowl of cereal before bed. Inside there's a group of officers talking at another table, and one enlisted man breaking down the serving line. It's late, and most of the people in the ship are in bed.
深夜的一天，戈雷尔中尉和来自圣地亚哥的电视摄制组和我正在返回客舱的路上，当时戈雷尔邀请我们去军官餐厅吃一碗麦片粥睡觉。里面有一群军官在另一张桌子上聊天，一名应征水兵正在清理服务线。天很晚了，船上大多数人都在睡觉。
So we're eating cereal and talking when the enlisted man appears with a huge tray of food. We all look at each other. No one asked him to fix us anything. Just thought you all might like a snack, sir, the enlisted man says to Gorell, and puts the tray on our table. The tray contains 12 chicken breast sandwiches, each with lettuce and a slice of American cheese on hamburger buns. There are four of us, and we already have our cereal. Apparently, the Powell Doctrine of overwhelming force applies to food service as well.
所以我们正吃着麦片粥聊天，应征水兵带着一大托盘食物出现了。我们互相看着。没人让他给我们弄什么。长官，只是以为你们可能想要点零食，应征水兵对戈雷尔说，并把托盘放在我们桌上。托盘里有12个鸡胸肉三明治，每个上面有生菜和一片美式奶酪，放在汉堡面包上。我们有四个人，而且我们已经有麦片粥了。显然，“鲍威尔主义”的压倒性力量也适用于餐饮服务。
Later in our cabin, Wendy, Ira, and I talk it over. Being on an aircraft carrier, we're surrounded on all sides by the lopsidedness of American military superiority. Just the very fact of the carrier itself-- no other country even has one like the Stennis. The US has 12. But it's the chicken sandwiches which somehow make that fact real.
后来在我们的舱室里，温迪、伊拉和我讨论了这件事。身为一艘航空母舰，我们被美国军事优势的倾斜性所包围。仅航母本身的事实——没有其他国家甚至拥有一艘像斯坦尼斯号那样的航母。美国有12艘。但正是那些鸡肉三明治让那个事实真实起来。
Such is the size and strength of the attention to detail, which fully conveys the sheer uncontested might of the American military. Not only does the Navy give each pilot one of the fastest, most expensive fighter planes in the world to fly, not only does it provide him with the most accurate bombs in the history of warfare to drop, it also feeds him at any hour of the day more chicken sandwiches than you can possibly eat. It gives him a room to hang out in, with his own official nickname on the chair, and a practice space for his band. Someone, somewhere, stitches Monkey Butt into his flight suit. The other countries don't have a chance.
这就是关注细节的大小和力量，这充分传达了美国军队纯粹且未受挑战的力量。海军不仅给每个飞行员提供世界上最快、最昂贵的战斗机之一，不仅为他提供战争史上最精确的炸弹供他投下，它还在一天中的任何时间给他提供比你可能吃掉的更多的鸡肉三明治。它给他一个房间待着，椅子上有他自己的正式昵称，还有给他的乐队排练的空间。某人，在某处，把“猴子屁股”缝进他的飞行服里。其他国家根本没机会。
You've never slept in bunk beds with your boss until you've slept in bunk beds with your boss on an aircraft carrier. By Navy standards, the room Ira and I shared was luxurious, only two of us, not 200 or 600. But the problem with the room, everybody warned us, was that it was right below the flight deck, and it could get kind of loud. And sure enough, we were woken up several times that first night by the thumps and the clanks of the planes landing and taking off. Still, we figured, we could manage.
除非你和你的老板在航空母舰上睡在双层床上，否则你永远不知道那是什么感觉。按照海军标准，伊拉和我共享的房间是豪华的，只有我们两个人，不是200或600人。但房间的问题，每个人都警告我们，是它就在飞行甲板下面，可能会有点吵。果然，我们第一天晚上被飞机起降的重击声和咔哒声惊醒了好几次。不过，我们想，我们能应付。
Then, the second night, a bus ran full speed into the wall by my head. That's what it sounded like. Like the steel wall six inches from the top of my head had just suffered a collision with a very fast-moving bus. It was the loudest sound I'd ever heard.
然后，第二天晚上，一辆公共汽车全速撞在离我头顶很近的墙上。听起来就是这样。就像我头顶六英寸处的钢墙刚经历了一场与高速移动公共汽车的碰撞。这是我听过的最大的声音。
And here's what it's like to be in a bunk bed with your boss on an aircraft carrier when you've just heard the loudest sound you've ever heard, if your boss is my boss. What happened next was this: the loudest sound I'd ever heard happened again. And I have to stress, this is not a normal loud sound, like a rock band or a car horn or even a stick of dynamite exploding. This is a sound that's only made when things that shouldn't happen happen. It's the sound of disaster, of destruction. It is the sound of catastrophe.
这就是当你听到你听过最大的声音后，在航空母舰上和你的老板睡在双层床上是什么感觉，如果你的老板是我的老板的话。接下来发生的是：我听过最大的声音又发生了。我必须强调，这不是正常的巨大声音，像摇滚乐队、汽车喇叭，甚至是炸药爆炸。这是一种只有在不该发生的事情发生时才会产生的声音。这是灾难、破坏的声音。这是灾难的声音。
I lay there stunned for a second, and then I heard Ira jerk into action, saw his feet swing down from the top bunk. I actually said the words, "You're right man," as I threw off my blanket and started to run. And then I looked behind me, and I saw Ira digging through his equipment. And I realized I was running for the door, and Ira was running for his tape recorder.
我呆立了一秒，然后听到伊拉采取行动，看到他的脚从上铺甩下来。当我扔掉毯子开始奔跑时，我实际上说了：“你是对的，伙计。”然后我向后看，看到伊拉在翻他的设备。我意识到我正跑向门口，而伊拉正跑向他的录音机。
(SUBJECT) IRA GLASS: One two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine. [INAUDIBLE]
一、二、三、四、五、六、七、八、九。（听不清）
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: While we waited for the loud sound to happen again, Ira and I handed the microphone back and forth between our bunks and recorded our conversation.
当我们等待巨大声音再次发生时，伊拉和我把麦克风在我们的铺位间传来传去，记录了我们的谈话。
(SUBJECT) ALEX BLUMBERG: If there was a problem, though, there would be alarms going off and stuff, right? I mean, it just wouldn't just be like a horrible accident and then nothing-- and then no sound, right? They'd be saying, all hands to your stations, that sort of thing, right?
如果有问题的话，会有警报响起之类的，对吧？我的意思是，那不会仅仅像一场可怕的事故然后什么都没有——然后没有声音，对吧？他们会说，全体人员就位，那类事情，对吧？
(SUBJECT) IRA GLASS: I'm sure if it really gets bad around here, there's bells of some sort.
我相信如果这里真的变得很糟糕，会有某种钟声的。
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: The loud sound never happened again, and eventually we fell sleep, though Ira left the tape recorder running just in case. We were out for maybe half an hour when we were woken up again.
那个巨大的声音再也没响过，最终我们睡着了，尽管伊拉为了保险起见让录音机开着。我们睡了大概半小时后又被叫醒了。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] control. Loss of feed in number two reactor plant. Reactor mechanical casualty assistance team, layer number two, reactor room.
（听不清短语）控制。二号反应堆工厂失去供给。反应堆机械事故救援队，二号层，反应堆室。
(HOST) ALEX BLUMBERG: "Loss of feed in number two reactor plant. Reactor mechanical and casualty assistance teams, report to number two reactor room." Casualty assistance teams? That can't be good, right? After half an hour in which I tried to convince myself that my stomach ache was not radiation sickness, and Ira tried to figure out how he could get down to the ship's nuclear reactors to report on the accident, another PA announcement came on, just like the first, but with one additional sentence.
“二号反应堆工厂失去供给。反应堆机械事故救援队，向二号反应堆室报告。”事故救援队？那不可能是好事，对吧？在我努力说服自己胃痛不是辐射病，而伊拉试图弄清楚他如何能深入到军舰的核反应堆去报道事故的半小时后，另一个广播公告响起了，就像第一个一样，但多了一句话。
(SUBJECT) PA SYSTEM: Reactor mechanical casualty assistance team, layer number two, reactor room. This is a drill.
反应堆机械事故救援队，二号层，反应堆室。这是一个演习。
(SUBJECT) ALEX BLUMBERG: At breakfast, we learned what had happened. The loud sound? That was a routine test for one of the catapults, and the PA announcement had been a routine drill. The two things were totally unrelated. Both things, they said, happened almost every day.
在早餐时，我们了解了发生了什么。那个巨大的声音？那是对弹射器之一的日常测试，而广播公告是一个日常演习。这两件事完全没有关系。他们说，两件事几乎每天都在发生。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Thank you very much, Alex, for that report.
非常感谢亚历克斯，带来那篇报道。
There's one more thing that happened on the Stennis that I keep thinking about in the weeks since we returned. It was at the end of our very last day there, which meant 10:40 in the morning. And Barbara Mendoza, the chief who had been kind enough to invite us to the chief's mess, took Alex and Wendy and I outside to the very back of the ship, the fantail, looking at the water and the sky. It's one of her favorite places on the Stennis.
在斯坦尼斯号上发生的一件事，我回来后的几周里一直记在心头。那是我们最后一天在那里，意味着上午10点40分。芭芭拉·门多萨，那位好心邀请我们去军士长餐厅的军士长，带亚历克斯、温迪和我去了军舰的最尾部，即舰尾，看着水和天空。这是她在斯坦尼斯号上最喜欢的地方之一。
(SUBJECT) BARBARA MENDOZA: I come out here every day before I go to bed. It's very peaceful. I do a lot of thinking out here. I relax a lot, and I really like it. I mean, look at it. It's beautiful. There's no other place to be.
我每天睡觉前都会到这儿来。这里非常平静。我在这里思考很多。我放松了很多，我真的很喜欢它。我的意思是，看它。它很美。没有其他地方可去了。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: We look out at the north Arabian Sea, the waters that military vessels have sailed for thousands of years. Persians were here 500 years before the birth of Christ. Alexander the Great sent ships here, the Ottomans, the Chinese, the Romans, the Portuguese, all of them great naval powers in their day.
我们看着北阿拉伯海，军事船只航行了数千年的水域。波斯人在基督诞生前500年就在这里了。亚历山大大帝曾派船到这里，奥斯曼人、中国人、罗马人、葡萄牙人，他们每一个都是当时伟大的海军强国。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Hey chief, do you ever think about the fact that you're serving over here in this particular ocean, this particular body of water, how long people have been traveling by sea across this?
嘿，军士长，你是否曾经想过你正在这片特定的海洋、这片特定的水域服役，人们通过海路跨越这里有多久了？
(SUBJECT) BARBARA MENDOZA: You know, I always wonder-- when I look at big bodies of water like this-- I always wonder how many ships are on the bottom of this floor. So that's one of the things that I like to think about when I'm out here. I wonder how many ships are out here on the bottom that never made it home. Hundreds? Over hundreds of them? From all the wars that we've been through.
你知道，我总是想——当我看着像这样巨大的水体时——我总是想知道有多少艘船在这一层的底部。所以这就是我在这里时喜欢思考的事情之一。我想知道外面底部有多少艘船从来没能回家。几百艘？超过几百艘？从我们经历的所有战争开始。
(INTERVIEWER) IRA GLASS: Here you are working for the mightiest navy in the history of the world.
你正在为世界历史上最强大的海军工作。
(SUBJECT) BARBARA MENDOZA: Isn't that cool? How cool is that?
那不是很酷吗？那有多酷？
(HOST) IRA GLASS: Off to the starboard side of the ship, we can see the USS Port Royal protecting our back. We Americans are here for now, while it lasts.
在船的右舷，我们可以看到“皇家港”号在保护我们的后方。我们美国人目前就在这里，只要它还能持续下去。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
（鸣谢）
Original music for this hour by John Kimbrough. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
本小时的原创音乐由约翰·金布罗创作。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
（资助鸣谢）
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who describes his personal life these days this way:
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他这样描述他这些天的个人生活：
It's like a love boat right now.
现在它就像一艘爱情之船。
(HOST) IRA GLASS: I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是伊拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播。